how's your braces well today we're on
the quest for the scariest game ever or
just a game that is so bad that it's
horrifyingly horrible either way we win
first game a load in Tokyo
oh god road signs how did this game know
I'm terrified of road signs when he
quickly we need to collect cranes all
right this one doesn't have a road it
crashed are you [ __ ] kidding me no no
you are not cry seeing right now on me
this game has 5-7 people rated this
fight fine fine I'll reload it no big
deal
alright man I'll just wait better then
but then dip it dip em then all right a
need a nap oh my god it begins again I
am so excited I know how the [ __ ] you
pull that [ __ ] off but good job there's
literally barrels in every [ __ ]
horror game ever and it crashed the
barrels Christ again please
praise the Lord 5 out of 5
wrist lace oh look it's Stefania what
the [ __ ] happened to my face who would
sleep in a place like that
good job feeling fabulous feeling really
great hashtag relatable I feel like I
can accomplish anything I love video
games
I'm stuck I'm [ __ ] stuck are you
[ __ ] my hands are so red that's
pretty hi friend
ah the [ __ ] are you doing why did I let
why am i letting him do that to me I get
to play now now it's first person now
what do you fellas think when the couch
again I'll turn off the TV and take her
to our room all right I got this the
remote what I told you about that demon
sacrifices Terry where do you go you
summon oh oh hey oh oh oh no that's I ah
[ __ ] I hate mannequins guys I'm not
throwing a party this week I know who
the [ __ ] invited you hey don't give me
that look
all right I've thrown many great parties
in definitely something going on here oh
there carrot
yeah Jimmy Karen what Karen stop
Karen no ah you're so stupid you
disgrace to the family Karen okay you're
not a disgrace to the family I don't
know what the [ __ ] to tell you Jesus
Christ is this what it's like to have a
baby my god Karen
you gotta sleep oh hey miss thing you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh she became it she became a dinosaur
now all right well it's an original
story I'll give you that spooky cats now
this is folly
now this is game play great great
greatest game of all time
okay this game finally don't worry if
the game has been [ __ ] then don't worry
because slender craft is gonna save our
game
hey assign all hey elemental first note
of eight what - [ __ ] how do you know it
that's right creeper I'm the boss I
drink south look jump that what the [ __ ]
was that mine caved I like man stop my
character second out of eight great wait
am ia creeper I think I'm the creeper
said you said you ice me that if you
City its actor man is a giant ass tree
right there there must be node on it yes
don't speak English I know a bloke where
Pato who laughs bad one anything until
up the final note oh my god stop stop
for the love of God all right you want
to kill me
uncanny valley i'll a merit by I should
get home
hey this games pretty pretty look at
that paint hey buddy how you doing are
you trying to follow me
what are you doing why it must be one of
my bros trying to figure out where I
co-signed a bomber poster all right cool
whoa damn that [ __ ] freaked me out
jesus [ __ ] christ but it was a dream
who's who sleeps with anacs car fund
that's a mixed level hipster [ __ ] no no
no no nice ass way to I didn't drive to
take a [ __ ] that bad is that it oh
they're coming all right cool oh my
favorite room how you friends doing
they're all intact good job ChIP chip
cheerio die die
what the [ __ ] just happened that's right
door how dare you
alright what happened in here I'm a
detective I'm ready to snoop out every
detail ha
I also know kung fu' um alright this one
oh Jesus are you all right is everything
good you guys are dead all right Cole
I'm gonna go freezing doors what's this
doing here
I don't know buddy I don't know buddy
boo but I have a bad feeling about this
what you're a [ __ ] okay I get into
laughs but then it's never stopped me
before
they locked you they locked me in there
asbestos
they think they can have some art that's
number one security guard in town
they're probably right
oh wait never mind I mean I did this on
purpose okay I'm gonna go this way
instead
no no shame on you shame on you robot
shame on you
how dare you stupid robots have no shame
not a great then you're walking now are
you sad stop right there criminal scum
hey you're not supposed to do that
what what what is happening we have him
strip his clothes okay damn it and start
up the Machine what one machine thank
you for playing on Kenny a demo good
demo I enjoyed it good taps good rectal
exams
I mean Anitha and ever thought I'd
enjoyed that much oh my god oh my god oh
my god this this is it this is the
scariest game pretty I dress up all
right this has been great
both down below for which game you
thought was the scariest one I want to
thank you much for watching and it's
always something else I'm Rovers
what do you want